[Musik]
im Schatten der Europäischen Zentralbank
liegt in Frankfurt am Main der
paul-arnsberg-platz im Jahr 2005 neu
angelegt wird er jetzt wieder komplett
abgerissen und dann für 1,4 Millionen
Euro neu gebaut der Platz war eine
unwirtliche Betonwüste fast ohne grün
für die meisten Anwohner eine kolossale
Fehlplanung
schauen Sie hin Betonplatten
unfreundlich da geht kein Mensch hin da
hatten da funktioniert niemals dieser
Platz da ist nichts der ist tot es ist
einfach nur rausgeschmissenes Geld was
er da veranstaltet hatten weil was will
man mit so einem Betonklotz da auf dem
Platz wo du nicht geliebt wozu habe ich
einen Platz in einem riesen Ausmaß wenn
ich mit ihm nichts anfangen kann
2005 hatte man den Paul arnsberg-platz
umgestaltet große Mengen Betonplatten
verbaut und ein paar Trompetenbäume
gepflanzt die wachsen aber nicht richtig
an und bleiben kümmerlich der Platz gibt
ein trostloses Bild ab die Stadt
versucht einige Reparaturmaßnahmen mit
Lastwagen werden bepflanzte Bauelemente
angekarrt die sollen für ein bisschen
Grün sorgen man installiert ein
sogenanntes Wasserspiel für 400.000 Euro
besser macht es das nicht der Platz
bleibt ein Desaster im Sommer heißt er
sich so auf dass ich hier niemand
gefällt
das ist so eine Hitze
morgens mittags und noch schlimmer
abends sie hätten im Sommer Spiegeleier
auf den plattenbraten können so heiß war
das im September wird tabula rasa
gemacht der Platz komplett abgeräumt
jetzt soll er ganz neu gestaltet werden
die Stadt Frankfurt sieht dem Abriss nur
anderthalb Jahrzehnte nach dem Bau keine
Verschwendung von Steuergeldern
schriftlich heißt es der Klimawandel
betrifft uns alle und die Stadt
Frankfurt stellt sich dem Problem in dem
Planungen hinterfragt und neue Wege
gegangen werden der paul arnsberg-platz
ist eines der Pilotprojekte für die
Stadt ein Pilotprojekt für die Anwohner
eine böse Fehlplanung die jetzt teuer
repariert werden muss man braucht
natürlich für das Stadtklima weitaus
mehr grün
und diese Erkenntnis setzt sich erst
viel zu spät durch das Wasser wird
weniger und weniger deshalb wir müssen
jede tropfe ausnutzen für uns in der
Natur für die Bäume für die Grünflächen
nach etlichen hitzesommern soll aus der
Betonwüste also endlich ein Platz zum
Wohlfühlen werden Klima angepasst
umgestaltet das hätte man besser einfach
schon vor 17 Jahren gemacht